mein name ist nina schenk und ich habe
heute ein thema mitgebracht was mich
seit heute morgen sehr bewegt und
eigentlich schon seit sonntagabend in
rage bringt und zwar sind es nicht wie
sie gerade sehen die schauspieler videos
sondern die reaktionen darauf was ist
passiert verschiedene schauspieler haben
sich zusammengeschlossen und der leitung
einer österreichischen produzentin um
sich gegen die kinder impfung
auszusprechen in diesem video ist nur
ein trailer der ganze film erscheint
noch sprechen sie darüber warum ein
kinder nicht impfen sollte unter anderem
sind dabei til schweiger miriam stein
oder auch nina treu man muss die
meinungen von diesen schauspieler nicht
mögen man muss die meinung auch nicht
akzeptieren aber man sollte die
respektieren denn zu einer demokratie
gehört immer die meinung des anderen zu
respektieren
aber das ist im internet nicht der fall
auch nicht in allen artikeln zu den
videos einige reaktionen würde ich ihnen
gerne vorlesen man muss ganz hart sagen
solche filme kosten menschenleben wer
bei solchen film mit macht macht sich
schuldig die botschaft des films herum
schwul bin die schauspieler werden in
sozialen netzwerken als schwul
beschimpft ihre ihr film würde
menschenleben kosten für mich ist das
nicht richtig weil man da auch über die
sinnhaftigkeit der kinder impfen
diskutieren
absolut ich wundere mich überhaupt über
die seltsamen polarisierten reaktionen
ich meine das ist eine branche die sonst
eigentlich immer davon lebt dass die
hörgewohnheiten sehgewohnheiten
aufbricht dass sie bürgerliches wegfegt
und jetzt sind plötzlich meinungen auf
einmal nicht mehr statthaft das finde
ich schon ganz seltsam mal abgesehen
davon dass so ein thema natürlich
öffentlich diskutiert gehört also danke
für diese für diesen anstoß zu einer
öffentlichen debatte also an sie haben
alles richtig gemacht also diese
vergiftung von debatten kennen wir doch
zur genüge ich kenne die seitdem es in
der öffentlichen sitzung gibt dann der
xl war teil nehme ich bin ständig mit
solchen attacken konfrontiert welche
köppel wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr als
ich wer sich daraus wagt und gegen die
kinder impfung argumentiert muss damit
leben punkt und sollte auch nicht zu
weinen anfangen ich kenne nur eltern die
nicht impfen lassen und zwar mit dem
argument erstens ist der impfstoff noch
nicht endgültig zugelassen haben alle
nur provisorische zulassung bis auf die
usa da ist bayern keck jetzt wirklich
offiziell zugelassen arzneimittel und
außerdem weiß man nicht wie so
impfstoffe wirken wenn die entwicklung
der kinder die körperliche entwicklung
die geistige entwicklung noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist noch unterwegs ist
gibt es auch jeden grund vorsichtig zu
sein also finde ich das was die künstler
hier sagen aus meiner sicht komplett
richtig also ich verstehe auch nicht die
kritik sozusagen angesagt kritik weil es
ist ja klar wenn man eine person der
öffentlichkeit ist dass man eben auch
mit gegenreaktionen rechnen muss und ich
glaube da geht es jetzt nicht primär um
das thema sondern ist es natürlich auch
die gesamte politisierung auch der
kroner pandemie und des impfens im
allgemeinen und auch in christian
drosten ist ja genauso vielen
anfeindungen ausgesetzt und es gibt da
eine sehr ausgeprägtes lagerdenken aber
ich glaube schon dass wenn schauspieler
die ambitioniert sind die bekannt sind
daneben auch mit seiner meinung
rausgehen dass sie dann auch mit dagegen
berechnen müssen und das dann von
kensington road finde ich falsch weil
ich finde kritik muss erlaubt sein aber
auch eine hypothek also ich muss sagen
solche geben wer bei solchen film mit
macht macht sich schuldig herumwirbeln
war noch mit das netteste ich finde ich
habe auch noch mehr kritik extra
aufgeschrieben ich finde es extrem
schwierig im zb 11 weber auch geschafft
nach sieben tagen vorbei hut ab vor dem
pflegeteam dieser es legitim die seit 18
jahren exzellente arbeit leisten während
schweiger und co ihn ins bein schießen
es ist ja dieses ihr sagt was dagegen
ihr schießt den pflegekräften ist wir
wollen dass menschen sterben neuer film
kostet menschen nehmen das kann auch
wirklich nicht mehr inhaltlich wie
gesagt da bin ich ja sozusagen offen
weil ja gesagt das möchte ich gerne den
eltern überlassen zum beispiel in erster
linie und ich bin ich habe keine kinder
deswegen würde es nicht wagen mich da
einzumischen auch wenn ich eine
persönliche haltung habe aber ich glaube
eben schon dass es darum geht
beispielsweise wenn meine meinung
geäußert und dann ist das von der
meinungsfreiheit gedeckt und das ist ja
auch das wofür wir ein steht und da
führen wir dieses wunderbare land aber
wenn er zum beispiel auf einem konzert
sagt dass sie das mit dem
infektionsschutz nicht so ernst nimmt
dann ist das nicht nur eine
meinungsfreiheit sondern sie wird damit
auch automatisch menschen gefährden die
sie dann auf sie hören und sich nicht
daran halten und deswegen glaube ich da
muss man einfach unterscheiden aber der
umgangston wird rauer und das sehen wir
gegenwärtig und da gibt's dann auch
lagerdenken also man kann ganz schwer
sich da raushalten oder positionieren
und sagen ich differenziere also ich
finde man kann sich da sachlich darüber
unterhalten man kann ja darauf antworten
warum man impfungen gerade für kinder
segensreich hilfreich gut findet man
kann argumentieren dass man keine
schlechten erfahrungen damit gemacht hat
mit kinderlähmung mit all den
wundstarrkrampf keuchhusten die man
segensreiche aus der welt geschafft hat
nur was man was nicht geht ist eine
haltung dass diese meinung nicht
öffentlich geäußert werden dürfen also
eine eine debatte bei der es nur ja oder
jahr gibt und ansonsten hat soll man den
mund halten das gibt es nicht sonst
immer auf dem weg in eine ganz steilen
rutsche herunter ich glaube da dreht
sich auch viel und til schweiger das ist
ja so ein erzfeind von vielen die ihn
genau beobachten und bei jeder
gelegenheit angreifen weil er halt auch
eine bestimmte form von filmen macht
weil ein bestimmter typus ist weil er
mit frauen auf dem bestimmter weise
umgeht das ist alles total verboten
heute in deutschland deutschland ist
sowieso viel verboten das denken wird
auch zunehmend verboten diese ganze
corona politik ist eine einzige
staatsideologie erstarrt und ich bin
jedem dankbar der gegen diese
staatsideologie anläuft denn ich will
nicht noch fünf jahre so leben wie ich
in den letzten zwei jahren gelebt habe
wir müssen unsere freiheitsrechte
zurückbekommen und dazu gehört auch die
freiheit des denkens und der diskussion
ich höre da mit interesse zu ist eine
interessante diskussion mir imponiert
diese reptil schweiger ich habe auch
schon gewisse äußerungen die er gemacht
hat da muss ich sagen weil ich nicht
immer absolut new style ist er quasi der
der deutsche tom cruise würde ich sagen
ist ist der til schweiger und sein
gremium
wassermühle gleiche nicht nur so mir
eben bei mir imponiert dass schon bei
diesem früheren video als da in
deutschland ein paar amok gelaufen sind
dagegen dass diese künstler diese
schauspielerin den mut haben in einer
wie es gesagt wird in einer polit
pandemie in einer völlig übersteuerten
zum teil religiös aufgeladenen diskurs
exklusiven minenfeld stimmungen hier
einfach mal zu sagen wir sind da dagegen
wir finden das nicht richtig und ich
kann das nachvollziehen ich meine die
kind also ich bin jetzt auch kein
virologe es wird er jetzt von
medizinexperten und alle kennen sich der
wahnsinn ich bin ein laie ich habe vier
kinder sie sagen die kinder wollen ja
bisher gar nicht der der solchen herz
diese pandemie und jetzt plötzlich
kommunal diese doctor strange löws diese
doktor selbst
der politik und der politik medizin und
die wollen jetzt den kindern auch noch
in die körpersäfte hineinregieren da
verstehe ich doch die eltern die sagen
nein und ich lebe hier das ziemlich ein
lichtblick in deutschland das ihr hier
noch schauspieler hat kulturschaffende
die es wagen der offiziellen politik
linie zu widersprechen das heißt es
sieht nicht nur staatsschauspiel und das
sind 21 jährigen schweiz nicht mehr nein
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das ist für
mich jetzt eine der besten nachrichten
als letzter zeit das geht aus gibt mir
hoffnung dass deutschland sich doch noch
in eine positive entwicklung positive
richtung entwickelt zusammen mit der
arbeit schweiger aus wir müssen hier das
positive betonen für luise ganzen
geschichte sehr wichtig nicht mich was
ich selbst finde das ehrlich gesagt die
aussagen also ich frage mich worüber sie
gerade sprechen weil so zu tun als wenn
wir hier unter freiheitsentzug leiden
würden als wenn es hier nur so eine
krone diktatur geber als wenn nur eine
meinung durch dass sich wer also ich
lebe ja in dieser stadt und ist schon
seit vielen jahren ich bekomme die
demonstrationen mit die finden
regelmäßig statt und da ist keiner der
menschen obwohl teilweise sogar der
holocaust relativiert wird obwohl
rassisten dabei sind ich muss da aber
diese menge aber
ich finde teil das immer so zu tun als
wenn wir so eine spirale des schweigens
hätten keine meinungsfreiheit also ich
glaube ich muss mal vergegenwärtigen
dass wir beiden ja sogar gemeinsam
hatten da war ich ja bei euch eine
talkshow im oktober letzten jahres und
habe mich gegen die masken pflicht
ausgesprochen nach hattest du mein bild
raus geklebt wie du mich ansetzt
anschaust wegen meiner äußerungen ist
okay gewesen fand ich zwar nicht gut
aber okay und jetzt habe ich auch mal
gewusst haben dass wenn ich habe storm
bekommen sondersgleichen war plötzlich
eine spur bleibt und da konntest du
nichts für du wolltest nur es war
eigentlich guter weg die diskussion auf
twitter zu holen ich wurde beleidigt
dass ich wirklich abends im restaurant
saß völlig fertig mit meinem leben und
dachte wie kann das sein und da habe ich
muss ich ehrlich sagen von dir und
patrick jetzt hier und schon leute in
der diskussion den respekt bekommen für
meine meinung zwar eine nette des
gesunden wir haben aber was auf twitter
gegen mich los ging nur weil ich gegen
die massen pflicht gesprochen habe war
fürchterlich es war wirklich erbärmlich
und da muss ich schon sagen in dem
moment hatte ich keine meinung das kann
man das ja konkretisieren ja gesagt dass
sozusagen die tatsache dass so eine
maske tragen tragen muss freiheitsentzug
ja und da habe ich einfach mehr
gleichheit in weichen sondern sich nicht
anstecken die vergleichsweise die
verhältnisse wie wir sie in ihrer hand
vorfinden gerne von frauen oder mehr
jahren beantragen dass er ordentlich als
freizeit regelmäßig sagt mir wir messen
an der hinrichtung ist die schulter aber
wirklich verwöhnt in diesen
individualisierten gesellschaft und
eines nicht schlecht sich hin und wieder
mal zu vergegenwärtigen worum geht's
hier eigentlich und ich sehe das anders
als du ich trage diese maske vor allem
zum schutz meiner umwelt auch wenn es
mich stört und natürlich hat sich vieles
verändert und damit hat sich auch unser
leben verändert aber ich glaube das ist
sozusagen der solidarbeitrag den wir
aufbringen sollten so hab ich das
gelernt ich komme aber auch aus einer
großfamilie ich komme aus maine
kollektivistischen kultur also ich bin
so sozialisiert und deswegen weiß ich
nicht ob mir das leichter fällt ich habe
keine ahnung aber ich bin eben immer
damit auch beschäftigten daran
interessiert zu gucken wo kann man auch
verbinden integrativ und das tut mir
natürlich leid dass du dafür angegriffen
also ich weiß ich das war auch gar nicht
viel habe ich wollte nur dazu sagen dass
die meinungsfreiheit habe ich da und ich
habe mir damals gesagt dass ich nicht
verstanden habe dass ich die maske auf
sie muss in einem komplett leeren
flughafen wo kein mensch war mir dann
die polizei hinterher gerannt ist es war
an einem beispiel was groß geschrieben
und so wieder die bäckerei da gehört
auch kein einem raum aber was ich sagen
wir es geht darum dass wir meinung
wieder respektieren müssen und da sie
damals auf twitter und auch das jetzt
mit den schauspielern passiert kann ich
furchtbar aber entschuldigung jetzt muss
ich aber auch mal sagen es werden dass
so viele dinge tabuisiert ist haben wir
gerade wieder gemerkt in halo an masken
pflicht ist natürlich muss sein und wird
auch weiter so bleiben ich bin aber
zweimal geimpft lassen sich auch ein
drittes mal impfen und dann will ich
verdammt noch mal irgendwann die maske
nicht mehr tragen müssen aber das wollen
wir ja kann ich ja das wollen dann
sollen sie sich impfen lassen und dann
soll das auch sagen hey ist das sage ich
auch schauen wir dann sehen wenn ich
doch totgeschlagen von wm und ich würde
gern ein neuer holzköpfe die hierauf
sich geäußert haben die uns gerne vor
schreiben möchten wir in diesem staat zu
leben haben und was wir diskutieren
dürfen
[Musik]